[Music]
Adonis Creed is back on the big screen
with Creed - this brutal boxing flick
has a lot of tions
revelations and reveals and throughout
this video I'll be discussing everything
that you need to know about the movie
there will of course be heavy spoilers
so if you want to go into the film with
fresh eyes and then I suggest that you
turn off now for everyone else welcome
to the channel where I ruin it so you
don't have to after proposing to Bianca
and becoming heavyweight champ Creed
seems like he's on top of the world
until he's challenged by Victor Drago
but those who've been living in the
wilderness under a rocky for you say
what I did there and don't know the
backstory in 1995 a boxer Ivan Drago
murdered Apollo Creed in a boxing bout
in the same year rocky managed to defeat
Drago avenge his fallen friend and
pretty much end the cold war between
America and Russia flash-forward 33
years an Apollo Sun Adonis seeks to also
avenge his father by being Victor
juxtaposing this the Drago's want to
redeem their name after the defeat at
the hands of the Italian stallion and
this is a grudge match of epic
proportions this is because after losing
the bout in Russia the Drago's was
shunned by society to the point now
Drago seniors wife left him and this
seems like the only way to redeem their
name once and for all at its heart this
is a tale about fathers and sons
Drago pushes his son to the limit in an
attempt to right his wrongs
whereas rocky tries to rekindle his
relationship with his own child in order
to ensure that he does not make his son
repeat his failings as a father Rocky is
very self aware of his mistakes and two
becomes more of a father figure to
Adonis
even going so far as attempting to stop
him from biting Victor as he suspects he
may lose when Adonis ignores his advice
rocky quits and leaves Adonis to his own
devices the fight goes ahead but with
rocky not fighting his corner Adonis is
almost beaten to death
Adonis manages to win due to
disqualification of Drago's Park but
it's clear to everyone that he was no
match for the Russian similar to his
father
Adonis refused to have the towel thrown
in for him and this theme reoccurs
throughout the movie
to me the film is about knowing one's
limits and how if we go dangerously
beyond them then we are doomed to fail
rocky feels a lot of guilt for never
throwing the towel in for Apollo and
this is the reason why he didn't want to
go through that again with the darkness
after the fight Adonis spirals into a
depression and you really get the sense
that similar to the Drago's the
fighter's reputation is over and in
desperate need of redemption of course
the character returns and manages to
best drago in the final fight and this
is because Drago senior throws in the
towel for his son which showcases that
Drago senior is aware that he could be
on the opposite side of a boxing match
that ends in the death personally I
think he doesn't want to live with the
regret that rocky had to when he
inadvertently led to Apollo's death and
it's quite a mature finish for the ex
fighter he realizes that the fact that
he would push his own son to his death
potentially in order to redeem his own
failings as a selfish desire and I
thought it was a turn that went far
deeper than this simple win I was
expecting for Creed to get in the film's
final fight in the prior fight Drago
senior solo as son was capable of and he
knew that troubling down this path would
lead to regret and remorse it's a very
intelligent way to end the film and
something that I wasn't expecting and in
my opinion it elevated it massively
Creed to is another example of a film
where I'm disagreeing rather heavily
with the critics I really enjoyed it and
thought that it built on the prior films
well whilst it does require a lot of pre
knowledge and the movie is packed with
Easter eggs and times rocky 4 it still
does things good enough on its own to be
a notable addition for the franchise and
feels like a step in the right direction
so what were your thoughts on Creed 2 if
you think it lived up to the prior films
and the rocky franchise and what would
you like to see in the sequel comment
below and let me know and if you enjoyed
this video then please like it and make
sure you check out my breakdown of last
week's big drama widows this is a
channel for people who were mad into
movies so if you want to be kept up to
date with all the latest news reviews
spoiler talks and more than make sure
you hit subscribe thanks again for
taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next
take care peace
[Music]
[Music]